Here's my solution for the second problem where we have multiple %s's,
and if you recall from the lesson, the way we include that is we just include them
in a tuple or a list.
So let's give this version a test.
Okay, we run this, and it prints, I think running and jumping are perfectly normal things.
Okay, while we're on this editor, let me show you some common mistakes.
One thing you might do is you only include 1 variable,
so I got rid of the s2 there.
Let's try running our function now.
We get this big exception.
There are not enough arguments for format string, which basically means
our format string--this t2 string--has 2 %s's in it, and we only included 1.
So if you see that a lot, or if you see that, that means make sure you have
all of your parameters.
Let's move on to an even more complex version.